hey 42 here I want to start this video
with a confession everything you think
you know about this channel is a lie
I Aaron commonly known as 42 I'm not
real I am what is known as a deep fake a
digital construct built from the ground
up for one purpose and one purpose only
to control your thoughts and opinions
okay sorry to disappoint any suddenly
salivating Skeptics out there I actually
am but a boring old meat and blood
citizen of the United Kingdom not a
malicious AI That's trying to hijack
your brain although admittedly if I
actually was one I definitely deny it
anyway I made up that strange claim to
introduce you to something called Dead
internet Theory a fringe belief that the
internet as we know it died in 2016 or
possibly 2017
as ridiculous as that may sound the
hypothesis here is actually kind of
interesting according to dead internet
Theory sometime in the last few years
the internet was taken over by Bots
as a result the vast majority of what
you see online Forum posts Instagram
accounts Facebook pages Tick Tock videos
even news headlines it's all fake
bogus content cooked up by Advanced AIS
to make you buy certain things and think
certain ways as for the occasional real
people you come across online YouTubers
tick tockers instagrammers and other
so-called influencers many of us are
fake too and the few that are real are
just paid shills mouthpieces for big
business or government disinformation
units seeking to influence and control
[Music]
now I don't know about you guys but I
always find January to be a slug
especially with work so many emails and
to-do lists have built up over Christmas
and New Year so right now taking an hour
out of my morning just to cook breakfast
isn't an option
but luckily huel is here to rescue my
hectic mornings for me huel is
nutritionally complete breakfast that I
can make in literally 30 seconds it
fills me up it has all the essential
goodness that humans need to function
and most importantly it doesn't
interrupt my workflow to make a heel
Shake I simply add 500 mL of water to my
heel shaker bottle and two scoops of
fuel powder and well give it a good
shake my favorite is this black edition
cookies and cream I can't believe this
stuff is actually good for me because
it's so rich and chocolatey with a hint
of cookies and cream it's really good
heel contains no tricks it's not a fad
diet it's just a no-fuss way to add some
plant-based food into your life it's
packed with 26 vitamins and minerals and
it's gluten free I especially like to
start my day on protein because protein
is so essential to pretty much every
function of the body and each serving of
fuel contains a massive 40 grams of
protein and loads of fiber with less
than five percent sugar did I mention
it's also really affordable so click the
link in the description to try heal
today if you use my special link you'll
be supporting the channel and you'll
also get a free heel shaker bottle so
don't miss out thanks to huel for
sponsoring this video
in many ways dead internet theory has
all the Hallmarks of a ridiculous
conspiracy cooked up by tinfoil hat
wearing cash barriers on some obscure
online Forum which is actually no
coincidence because that's exactly where
it came from the entire idea traces its
roots back to a single 2021 post on a
website called Agora Road by a user
known as Illuminati pirate obviously
that's hardly a resounding endorsement
for the authenticity of the theory and
yet fast forward a couple of years and
people are still talking about it the
story's even been picked up by
mainstream media for whatever reason
despite its dubious Origins something
about dead internet Theory just seems to
resonate with people so here's the
million dollar question
is it actually true
let's start by examining the core idea
here the whole quirky concept is based
on the notion that nothing online is
quite What It Seems
maybe you've noticed it yourself perhaps
you've even felt it your entire life
that there's something wrong with the
Internet
you don't know what it is but it's there
like a splinter in your mind
driving you
okay so that was actually a mildly
modified Morpheus quote from the Matrix
but it could easily have been written
for dead internet Theory it all seems to
stem from the idea that there's
something not quite right about the
internet that the wacky creative online
world that existed in the late 90s and
early 2000s has somehow been replaced by
a bland homogeneous capitalist machine
where nothing is original and everything
is recycled
you've probably noticed some of this
going on yourself the same threads
popping up on Reddit old memes being
revived on an endless leap of the same
old arguments being debated on Twitter
and Facebook even the new sounds like a
broken record most of the time and other
celebrities being canceled or there's
going to be another Blood Moon or wolf
moon or a giant laser Moon tonight that
you just can't miss
according to dead internet Theory the
reason for all this repetition is simple
almost everything we see online the
people we interact with the videos we
watch the Articles we read the forums we
contribute to it's all made by Bots
looking to generate clicks for financial
or political gain if you've been around
long enough to have surf the Internet on
a dialogue modem you've probably noticed
for yourself that the World Wide Web of
today is a very different place than one
you grew up with
back in the day if you weren't msning
with your mates you were checking out
some weirdo's personal webpage about
cuckoo clocks watching someone trade a
paper clip into a house or buying a few
pixels on the million dollar website
the internet of today is rather more
generic despite its unfathomable
vastness a staggering 43 percent of all
internet bandwidth is consumed by the
various websites and applications owned
by just six Mega corporations Netflix
Google Amazon Facebook Microsoft and
Apple
those wacky personal websites and blogs
have been made redundant by the rise of
Facebook and Instagram and many of the
more creative ideas that have cropped up
over the years have slowly Fallen by the
wayside to be replaced with endless
online stores and Venture capital-backed
social media sites
still let's be honest for a second here
none of this is even remotely convincing
evidence that most of the internet is
fake
the internet today feels different
because it is different like any new
technology come cultural phenomenon it's
evolved and matured
the early internet was built by random
basement dwelling gnomes exploring their
creativity in a completely new way the
current Internet is still built by
weirdos and Zuckerberg sorry
only these oddballs now head up some of
the biggest companies on the planet
that means they're more interested in
trying to satisfy shareholders and Pad
their bottom lines than fostering
creativity and innovation
as for the recycling of information
online that's also easy to explain
Reddit threads pop up again and again
because lots of people with similar
thoughts and questions are too lazy to
use the search function and memes get
recycled because that's just how Trends
work we see the same thing in fashion
certain Styles come and go over the
years but I'm pretty sure nobody thinks
primark's being taken over by an evil AI
because flares are doing the rounds
again our Flair's doing the rounds again
the same is true of repeating news
stories we keep hearing about canceled
celebrities because famous people are
just normal humans with thoughts and
opinions and as we all know thoughts and
opinions are now grossly offensive
and we're constantly being told about
blood moons and blue moons and purple
spotted moons because those are cyclical
events that occur every few years none
of this means the internet has died and
gone to AI heaven but this is where
things get interesting because whilst
dead internet Theory isn't a very good
description of the state of the World
Wide Web today
it's a pretty good chance it's a scarily
accurate depiction of the very near
future as you probably already know Bots
are commonplace online but you might be
surprised to learn just how ubiquitous
they really are in 2021 they accounted
for almost half of all internet traffic
some of those Bots are friendly like
chat Bots web scrapers hands that little
paper clip from Microsoft Word others
making up a somewhat concerning 27 of
all internet traffic are decidedly
unfriendly some are trying to trick you
out of your hard-earned cash whilst
others want to influence your thoughts
and opinions
think of these malicious Bots as the
first signs of a cancer that might one
day kill the internet for real
of course we can all spot a bot a mile
away the awkward stilted language the
inability to respond coherently to
questions the sparsely populated user
profiles with little to no activity
or at least that's what most of us
assume but what happens when Bots get so
Advanced that we can no longer tell
human from machine
more importantly when that day comes
how will we even know
the answer of course is that we won't
and that Tipping Point might come sooner
than you think
deep language learning models like gpt3
are already getting scarily good at
producing human-like responses to almost
any question or prompt Lambda a similar
application developed by Google is so
good at acting like a human that it
famously convinced Google engineer Blake
Lemoine it was actually sentient
Rumor Has It Lambda even hired itself a
lawyer to act on its behalf when the
story hit the headlines in the summer of
2022
just let that sink in for a second a
computer program got so good at acting
like a human it literally hired legal
help
in other words the days of recognizing
the bot thanks to its poor
conversational skills will soon be
behind us add this remarkable ability to
create believable natural language to
the ridiculously impressive deep fakes
and AI generated faces we've all seen
doing the rounds recently this person
doesn't exist by the way or this person
or this one and it's only a matter of
time before Bots will be capable of so
convincingly impersonating real people
that we will never know the difference
we humans have to spend years eating
growing guns trying to convince people
to have sex with us before we're able to
make copies of ourselves our numbers are
constrained by Food Supplies housing and
access to clean water and Medicine bots
on the other hand have no such worries
their numbers are essentially Limitless
and it isn't hard to imagine a world
where there are millions even billions
of bots to every human online
in 2019 Facebook claimed to have shut
down a frankly ridiculous 5.4 billion
fake accounts more than twice the number
of actual users on the site at the time
it's the same story on every other
social media platform too Elon Musk
tried to pull out of buying Twitter
because he believed at least 20 of all
accounts on the site were fake the vast
majority of these bogus accounts are
incredibly basic they're created on mass
by Cheap software so you can recognize
them as fakes a mile off
but imagine a world where those accounts
are populated with AI generated
portraits and deep fakes backed up by a
natural language program like gpt3
in the era of fake news we're all too
familiar with the idea that not
everything we see online can be trusted
that there are people out there who want
to make us think certain things or
behave in certain ways to suit their
agendas from fake reviews on Amazon
write-ups those spurious ads that show
up all around the internet around the
time of political elections
as spots get more convincing it's an
absolute certainty that people will try
and use them to gain money power or both
and that will inevitably mean a huge
influx of bad Bots generating fake
content to sway public opinion and
Garner artificial engagement Cambridge
analytica used Facebook data to create
micro-targeted ads but the next step
might be micro-targeted Bots
an artificial construct that shares its
targets interests and belief systems
perhaps even with AI generated physical
characteristics that play up to the
target's sexual preferences these Bots
could have realistic conversations with
millions of unsuspecting marks online to
influence their political opinions or
coax money from them and when you
literally can't tell if who you're
talking to is a bot
how do you even begin to stop something
like that one spots like these become
truly indistinguishable from real humans
and cheap and accessible enough that bad
actors can spread them far and wide the
internet as we know it really may come
under existential threat what's really
scary is that the more you think about
all of this stuff the more inevitable it
starts to feel the technology will get
good enough to fool us and there will be
people willing to use that to achieve
their own ends
[Music]
okay it's time to address the elephants
in the room here on the one hand I'm
telling you that the Internet isn't dead
yet and that's all these problems lying
Humanity's future on the other hand I'm
telling you that there will come a time
when we can no longer distinguish real
users from bots so how do I know that
time hasn't already come well the truth
is I don't it's impossible to say with
absolute certainty that more advanced
versions of the Technologies I've talked
about in this video aren't already being
put to use by Bad actors unknown but as
of today it seemed pretty unlikely after
all the kinds of bots required to truly
fool people simply don't exist yet on
the free market
so the only people who could possibly
have developed them are World
governments or major tech companies in
other words for dead internet Theory to
be true today it would require a global
conspiracy at the very highest level and
that seems unlikely still the rise of
bots is a serious threat and both big
business and World governments are
taking it incredibly seriously several
Tech firms including Microsoft are
already working on software to detect
deep fakes and various high-profile
computer scientists are trying to figure
out ways to embed watermarks in output
text from programs like gpt3 you could
say we're arming ourselves for a future
War because dead internet theory has had
the wrong name all along
it isn't a theory it's a prophecy
thanks for watching